Ernest Hemingway was a man's man he was
a war hero a big-game hunter and
adventurer and above all else a
storyteller yet his was a life filled
with contrasts during his early years
the future mattre man's mother dressed
and treated him as a girl met his own
son Gregory would become a transvestite
he was also known as Papa Hemingway but
he had a distant relationship with his
own three sons in the midst of the
glowing tributes that the world heaped
upon him he sunk to terrible those
causing turmoil as he racked up awards
and then finally in an act of
desperation he took his own life to say
that Hemingway was a complex individual
this perhaps the ultimate understatement
and in today's biographic video we're
going to do our best to discover the
real man behind the veneer of Papa
Hemingway
[Music]
Ernest Miller Hemingway was born on July
the 1st 1899 to Edie and grace Hemingway
ed was a doctor in the Chicago suburb of
Oak Park grace was a talented opera
singer who had been forced give up a
promising career due to poor eyesight
she was to replace the adulation she
could have received by being a star with
an abnormal obsession with her children
for the first six years of his life
young Ernie was dressed and treated as a
girl by his mother she had always wanted
twin girls and made her son play that
role too his older sister Marceline
as if to counter the feminizing
influences of his wife Edie who was a
keen outdoorsman would take his son
camping alongside Lake Michigan for two
months every year the Ernest was allowed
to dress as a boy and was introduced to
the manly arts of hunting and fishing
Hemingway though he remembered his
father as a cruel man and it was often
harsh to his children and if they
misbehaved after whipping them with a
razor strap he would make them pray to
God for forgiveness the son developed a
deep hatred for his father relating that
he would sometimes go into the shed
shoulder his father's hunting rifle and
line up the old man in his sights still
he was able to restrain himself from
pulling that trigger now in high school
earnest strived to be the center of
attention he was popular with his
classmates throwing himself into every
game activity or prank yet despite his
enthusiasm he was not a very good
sportsman still wanting to impress he
would make up stories about his prowess
on the football field to please friends
and family it was in the creation of
these tall tales that Ernest Hemingway
was to discover his true gift as a
writer
[Music]
it was Hemingway's English teacher that
noticed his talent with the pen and
encouraged the boy to try out for the
school newspaper he won a place on the
writing team and was soon to publish his
first story the fame of that story would
resonate with Hemingway for the rest of
his life
coming to a tragic conclusion forty five
years later the short story it was
called judgment at mana town and it was
about a hunter who ends his life in a
suicide the story was well received in
Hemingway was spurred on to pursue a
career in journalism against the wishes
of his father who fully intended Ernest
to become a doctor the boy's uncle who
was the Friends of an editor at the
Kansas City Star arranged an
apprenticeship as a cub reporter the
seventeen-year-old was to handle the
crime beat Hemingway absolutely threw
himself into this job the first task was
to devour the star style book which was
based upon a unique abbreviated prose
style it demanded the use of short
sentences and introductory paragraphs
along with simple language with an
emphasis on a vigorous English Hemingway
would recall that this was the best
writing advice that had ever received
[Music]
the entry of the United States into the
first world war in 1917 was a major
turning point in Hemingway's life
the patriotic fervor that was sweeping
the nation's youth coupled with his
innate enthusiasm for adventure swept
him up as he tried to join the army
rejected because he had defective vision
he tried again this time applying to the
Red Cross ambulance division in Italy
before in u.s. well he was on a ship to
Europe it was in Italy that Hemingway
was to get his first experience of the
manly camaraderie and freedom that was
to mean so much to him he was able to
drink gamble and corrals into the early
hours with absolute impunity yes what he
really longed for that was combat far
away from the front lines his days were
mainly spends in monotonous dreary tasks
he confided to a friend I'm fed up
there's nothing here but scenery and too
damn much of us I'm going to get out of
this ambulance section and see if I
can't find out where this war is already
soon the war well it came to him on July
the 8th 1918 he was delivering chocolate
rations and cigarettes to Italian
soldiers on the PAF River he got caught
in the middle of the German offensive
from the other side of the water a bomb
exploded throwing Hemingway to the
ground the soldier alongside him was
killed but Ernest escaped with shrapnel
wounds to his leg despite this he
managed to carry a wounded soldier to
safety before collapsing into
unconsciousness
Hemingway well he now became a patient
of the Red Cross Hospital in Milan and
it was in this hospital where he found
his first love lying in bed he became
captivated with an American volunteer
nurse by the name of agnes von kurowsky
during his months recuperation Ernest
and Agnes explored the sights of Milan
together Hemingway he became enamored
with the darker Beauty who was 7 years
his senior
her feelings however they were not so
strong despite agreeing to marry him at
the war's end on New Year's Eve 1918
Hemingway was discharged from the Red
Cross and returned to the family home in
Oak Park he took on the persona of a
returning war hero telling the local
paper that he was a soldier in the
Italian army and relate
we had been personally decorated by the
Italian King for bravery something that
totally never happened Hemingway's
post-war high it was shattered by a
breakup letter from Agnes in it she
wrote I am now and always will be two
walls and that's the truth and I can't
get away from the fact that you're just
a boy a kid
this through earnest into a tailspin he
spent months loafing around the house
into this fed up mother finally tired of
his moping around threw him out grace
well she gave him some sounds and
sobering advice unless you my son Ernest
cease your lazy loafing and trading on
your handsome face to fool gullible
little girls and neglecting your duty to
God and your Savior Jesus Christ unless
you come into your manhood
there is nothing before you but bankrupt
see whether this jolt of reality woke
him up or not is still uncertain but
what we do know is that it was enough to
get Ernest out of his funk and on his
way to Chicago there P wrote articles
for the Toronto Star and worked odd jobs
to support himself at a party one night
Ernest met a young woman by the name of
Hadley Richardson Hadley was on a visit
to the big city from San Luis having led
a sheltered life under the influence of
a domineering mother yet she an earnest
hit it off immediately and despite the
fact that she was eight years older than
him it seems younger me had a thing for
older women the relationship it
blossomed nine months later earnest and
Hadley they were married a guest at the
wedding was showered Anderson an
up-and-coming writer who earnest
befriended Anderson encouraged the
newlyweds to move to Paris he gave
honest letters of introduction to
literary friends he resided on the left
bank managing to secure a position as a
foreign correspondent for the Toronto
Star Hemingway took his bride and
departed for a new life in Europe
[Music]
Hemmingway he quickly inserted himself
into the literary set on Paris's left
bank the couple moved into a small flat
which sat next to a popular dancehall
bus drawing on Hadleys trust funds
Hemingway also rented a room on the top
floor of a shabby hotel here he spent
his mornings perfecting the craft of
writing he told himself that all he
needed to do was write one true sentence
Bart for Ernest Hemingway being a writer
meant seeing and tasting and doing he
spent hours observing people in Paris
cafes chatted freely with strangers and
spent long hours drinking with his
writing buddies in Paris Hemingway he
was to come under the guidance of
celebrated author and playwright
Gertrude Stein she helped him to Paris
words down to the essence of the idea
and perfects the style for which he
would ultimately become famous in 1923
the Hemingway's that they took a trip to
Spain sparking a lifelong love affair
with the Spanish culture and people
Ernest also fell in love with the
national obsession of bullfighting in
Pamplona
he took his 6-month pregnant wife to
watch the Running of the Bulls while she
hid her eyes from the spectacle her
husband was spellbound by the power and
the passion of the events anyway it
would return to the Running of the Bulls
in Pamplona in the coming years bringing
a secession over literary friends with
him
[Music]
these excursions they formed the
backdrop to his first novel The Sun Also
Rises through his association with f
scott Fitzgerald Hemingway's work came
to the notice of Charles Scribner
publishers who published the Sun Also
Rises in 1926 this was Hemingway's real
breakthrough proving to be both a
commercial and critical success it has
showed in a new minimalistic writing
style for which the world was more than
ready however not everyone was so
impressed by this book his mother sent
him this scathing note surely you have
other words in your vocabulary besides
damn and bitch as Hemingway's star
elevators his private life began to
disintegrate
he had frequent fallings out with his
literary pals as he assumed the role of
master to their apprenticeships his
temper it was volcanic sometimes lead
fistfights and things unfortunately they
were no better at home
Ernest threw himself into a passionate
affair with a friend of his wife by the
name of Pauline Pfeiffer hadley feeling
deeply betrayed by both sides gave
Ernest 100 days to decide who he wanted
to be with
he chose the more cosmopolitan Pfeiffer
and walked out his wife and son
[Music]
anyway he also walked out on Paris he
and Pauline who had made a second wife
moved to the island of Key West Florida
here
Ernest reinvented himself as a deep-sea
fishermen integrating himself with a
group of hard working and hard drinking
seafarers who were a world away from the
gentle intellectuals that had left
behind in Paris fishermen Hemingway
reveled in the machismo of his new
lifestyle during the day he fished along
the Cuban coast and at night he smuggled
rum for his local hangout with the
proceeds rolling in from the Sun Also
Rises and his next novel The Farewell to
Arms he built his own boat called the
pillar and set about becoming the
world's greatest deep-sea fishermen he
proceeded to win every fishing contest
on the Atlantic when the locals became
upset he told them that they could win
their trophy back but first they had to
last three rounds in a boxing ring with
him and well nobody could but still
during all of this time Hemingway's love
it was writing heroes a 5 a.m. each day
and worked at his typewriter until
midday during this time he would give
his total focus to the written word then
after lunch he would throw himself into
his other life that of the hard-living
heavy drinking man of action
[Music]
during the Keywest years Aniston Pauline
had two children of their own both of
them putting Pauline through marathon
periods of labour and then well she
proved to be a pretty terrible mother
the woman who clearly did not like the
inconvenience of having children and
they way himself well he was also a
lousy father he would have periods of
intense interest in his boys and then
completely ignore them for months at a
time
in 1933 having wait discovered a whole
new world of adventure when he set out
on a hunting Safari in Africa he was
mesmerised by the natural beauty of the
Serengeti Plain but just as he was
getting into the hunt he was struck with
a terrible bout of dysentery he was
flown to a hospital in Nairobi to
recover the plane flew over the majestic
Mount Kilimanjaro providing the
inspiration for his most celebrated
short story via snows of Kilimanjaro
after his recovery
Hemingway returned to the Hunts where he
managed to bag Buffalo antelope and
lions during all this time he was
soaking up the atmosphere for inclusion
in later works of fiction back in Key
West
Hemingway continued his hard living
lifestyle during the early thirties he
began an affair with an American woman
who lived in Havana Ernest would spend
increasing amounts of time with her in
Cuba while is frustrated wife struggled
to cope with the children then in 1936
he began an affair with Martha Gellhorn
a journalist and writer
Gellhorn had the same sense of
journalistic adventurous Hemingway and
in 1937 they made the decision to cover
the Spanish Civil War together
Hemingway arrived in Spain as a reporter
for the American newspaper Alliance
however he soon became involved in a
dutch film production called the spanish
earth when the screenwriter quit he took
on the duties for himself after a few
months he returned to America showing
the film in Hollywood and raising
$20,000 for these Spanish Republicans
his month in Spain provided the basis
for Hemingway's best-selling novel about
the Civil War for Whom the Bell Tolls
those months well they also fueled the
flames of passion with Martha Gellhorn
a short time after returning to Key West
he divorced Pauline so that he could
marry Martha in 1939 the newlyweds they
moved to Cuba they settled into a
beautiful villa on the outskirts of
Havana and here the couple were to write
during the day and then explore the nice
life that Havana had to offer Cuba was
also
Portsmouth's paradise allowing Hemingway
to indulge his great passion for
deep-sea fishing
Hemingway well he soon met an aging
Cuban fisherman by the name of Gregorio
Fuentes
they became fishing buddies with
Hemingway basing the character of
Santiago and his Pulitzer prize-winning
novel the old man in the sea upon
Gregorio during the hurricane season in
Cuba the Hemingway's they decided to
live in Sun Valley in Idaho here
Ernest he was able to partake in the
hunting and freshwater fishing that had
done with his father as a boy during
this time he became close friends with
stars Gary Cooper and Marlene Dietrich
he took on the life of something of a
celebrity himself Errol Flynn Jane
Russell and Ingrid Bergman were regular
visitors to Sun Valley back in Cuba he
would insane the likes of Spencer Tracy
and the Duchess of Windsor at the
Floridita bar in Havana but it was
Hemingway himself who was the
acknowledged star of Havana the locals
they were always delighted to have him
in their midst they were just as
impressed with his ability to drink
anyone under the table as they were with
his literary Fame yet even as his wild
lights on the town in Havana became more
decadent Hemingway never strayed from
his disciplined writing regimen he
continued to produce quality work with
religious zeal one true sentence at a
time and it was during this time that
international accolades began showering
Hemingway in response to for whom the
bells toll this was widely regarded as a
literary masterpiece Ernest Hemingway
the writer was transforming himself into
Papa Hemingway the white-whiskered
literary genius who was also the big
loud and burly alpha male
[Music]
when World War II ignited it also
created tensions in far-off Havana
Martha Gellhorn Hemingway put her career
ahead of her family and set off to
Europe as a war correspondent
bable Hemingway was furious telling
everyone within earshot that he had a
good mind to follow after her and kick
her ass good and Teller she should
either come home or go to military
school meanwhile Martha was becoming
politically active in support of the
Allies she encouraged Hemingway to use
his influence to rally support he
ignored her pleas but finally left for
London as a correspondent for Colliers
magazine he joined the RAF on bombing
missions and followed the fourth
infantry across Normandy in the wake of
the d-day invasions on returning from
the war true to form the Hemingway
greatly exaggerated the party played in
defeating the Germans just as he had
done at the end of World War one the
military got word of his claims and
began looking further into them they
discovered that Hemingway had violated
his status as a noncombatant reporter on
many occasions and he was charged with
numerous rule violations when it came to
his defense a number of high-ranking
officers testified with one stating that
Hemingway was without question one of
the most courageous men I've ever known
fear is a stranger to him having wait he
was cleared of all charges and later
awarded a Bronze Star for bravery as a
war correspondent
[Music]
Oh Wars ends
Martha left the marriage fed up with her
husband's chauvinistic tendencies Bart
Hemingway well he already had a
replacement in the wings it was a fellow
war correspondent by the name of Mary
Welsh
Mary would be by his side right until
the end
in the late 1940s Hemingway's excessive
drinking began taking a toll on his
physical and mental health for the first
time the quality of his writing began to
suffer which was hugely frustrating for
him finally after a trip to Italy during
which he engaged in a passionate affair
with a girl in her 20s he published
across the river and into the trees the
critics they absolutely slammed it and
for the first time Hemingway felt the
sting of a literary rejection the
consensus was that the old man no longer
had the gift for Hemingway well this was
like a red flag to a bull he completed
his next novel in just eight weeks the
novel was the old man of the sea and
became the defining work of his career
the aging champ he had regained his
title with a vengeance silencing the
critics and claiming the 1953 Pulitzer
Prize for Literature then in 1954
Hemingway he was on safari in Africa
when his light plane went down in the
jungle smashing his head against the
door to open it he saved the life of all
on board but suffered permanent head
injuries in the wake of the Cuban
Revolution Hemingway's left of Honor in
July of 1960 and moved to Idaho here his
health both mental and physical rapidly
deteriorated he was admitted to the Mayo
Clinic and given electroshock therapy to
treat his depression this robbed the
master word Smith of his greatest
writing tool his memory and without that
yet nothing Ernest Hemingway committed
suicide with his favorite hunting rifle
on July the 2nd 1961 so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos just like this twice a
week we cover a whole range of people
some of which you can find link to on
the screen now so be sure to check those
out and as always thank you for watching